le bâtiment des poussins ici ils ont
deux jours
1200 au total bien au chaud un peu plus
loin d'autres d'une dizaine de jours des
pousses aller en martinique le calme et
la tranquillité sont de rigueur il
s'agit de ne pas les effrayer
c'est très important pour pas justement
qui ce groupe
et puis c'est ouf donc c'est beaucoup
d'heures do sol patients soient pas
d'énervement pas de stress
vous êtes formés et cette image oui j'ai
fait des formations des sûr j'ai
commencé sa formation mais au fur et à
mesure mais j'ai quand même été nous
former laurence mauger est ainsi
éleveurs engraisseurs de volaille depuis
une vingtaine d'années un petit élevage
de poulets fermiers
ils ont donc le droit de se balader en
pleine nature ici ils ont un mois et
demi et là ils sortent au fond ils ont
un parcours et ben voilà c'est le
bonheur quoi elles sont heureux ici ils
mangent ils boivent ils peuvent aller
vraiment s'amuser
et vous n'avez pas de prédateurs mois à
la mangouste c'est trop gros c'est
beaucoup trop gros pour la mangouste
elle ne va pas les attaquer par contre
le soir ça peut être à magny cours et la
halle et non patchées donc je les ai un
jour je les élèves jusqu'à 71 jours 72
jours et après la l'abattoir des
chauffeurs viennent chercher sur place
nous sommes dans les hauteurs des anses
d'arlet pas de chlordécone sur son
terrain après vérification comme ça je
sais et bien comme ça je sais que je
suis ok que je peux mais animaux peuvent
aller dehors manger de l'herbe et et que
je donne un aliment frit forme
oui ça fait un petit moment
dès le départ des poules est confiée à
une coopérative laurence mauger 60 ans
se donne encore quelques années avant de
prendre sa retraite
[Musique]